well here's a hollywood couple hoping to
make their union official
sarah highland and bachelorette alum
wells adams these two were supposed to
get married last august but the pandemic
postponed all of that
don't worry though sarah told lauren
zema she's got it all figured out
we're getting married this year no
matter what where they're having a
wedding i'll sign papers on the kitchen
table right now if
need be oh i love that so you're like
just get it done even if it's in the
living room
i'll talk to wells about it but yes
[Laughter]
well sarah's actually had some practice
when it comes to lockdowns
this is her third quarantine after
having two kidney transplants
my second transplant i found myself
really really getting into skin care
purely because
it was the one thing that i could
control and it helps me
really focus on self-love and self-care
we teamed up with sarah and olay to help
everyone practice a little self-love
i always like to take moments in the
morning and the night time to really
focus on myself
so for me i really love the olay
regenerist mineral spf
for the day because it blends really
really well into my skin
and then at night time i use olay's
retinol 24 moisturizer
because dirty retinol give me the
and i'm like heading to get this stuff
now it's available at walgreens at
walgreens.com
and they're amazing products for an
affordable price and you're already in
walgreens anyway
trying to find toilet paper so why not
[Music]